[Music]
today
we're extremely excited to welcome eric
garcetti the mayor of los
angeles before i turn it over to
our interviewer rex woodbury
and eric i just wanted to add one
personal anecdote
about eric back in the 1990s after i
graduated from college
i went to oxford to study for two years
and eric was a year ahead of me he and
his future wife were both rhodes
scholars
now this was at a time when bill clinton
who was also
a rhodes scholar had just been elected
president
and so that was very much on people's
minds and
right after i arrived at oxford i went
for a walk
around the oxford campus with another
american
who was in eric's class and he said to
me john
he said you know there are a lot of
americans here
who think they're going to be president
of the united states
he said you're going to meet a ton of
them and he said but but there's
actually one person in my year
who is going to be president united
states and that's eric garcetti
so i don't want to set the expectations
too high for eric's uh
interview but um but uh he's certainly
on still on that trajectory that was
identified way back in uh maybe those
many years ago and
and uh we're really really proud to have
him come speak to us today at the gsb
thank you eric
yeah thank you dean lovin and welcome
mayor garcetti we're we're very glad to
have you here today
yeah thank you it's great to be with you
and dean levin you're doing so well to
that last part you know why would you
wish that upon any friend
well it has been a somewhat eventful few
weeks in uh politics so
we're happy to have you here yeah it has
been it has been a remarkable
um you know a lot of people wonder what
history feels like
to be living through it this this is it
i mean life doesn't radically change
when you're living through a historical
moment
but it is an exceptional um an
exceptionally electric moment
um both in shocking ways and both in in
what is possible so it's a really good
time to be having this talk yes and as
dean lemon alluded to you've been a
leader on on various issues and
you've been mayor for seven years now
reelected in 2017 with 81 percent of the
vote
you lead the third largest metropolitan
economy in the world after new york and
tokyo and
i do want to get into all of that but i
want to back up and and kind of
understand how you got here
so you've said a lot that you have grown
up
wanting to change the world um when
change the world happens to be part of
the stanford gsb motto here
i'm curious what are your earliest
memories or or what was
the first part of your upbringing or
parenting that led you to really want to
have that impact on the world
well you know i can't remember a time
when i didn't want to um i think
it's in some people's dna in most
people's dna that we don't accept the
status quo
and and i think we look at the world it
doesn't have to be in a negative way but
we see what is imperfect about it
we see what the holes are we often see
if we look carefully what we don't see
and we can hear what we don't hear so
who's missing
and what voices aren't there and maybe
it's a little bit a combination of being
this
hybrid human um half latino half-jewish
being kind of a border crosser which i
say provocatively obviously my
ancestors crossed borders but being able
to navigate between cultures
always made me see really um you know as
a jew the whole idea of tikkun olam of
healing a broken world
and as a mexican-american you know
seeing what
that you know i i've passed in plenty of
places where people don't know that i'm
latino so hearing what people
say about you when they think you're not
there as well as being able to be
inside um institutions and organizations
i've always seen what needed to be
changed i think the other thing i'd say
is definitely my parents and and those
family background my grandfather who was
a dreamer before that term existed from
mexico who never
finished junior high school but his life
becoming a citizen
and enabling me to be where i am today a
mayor of that city that took him in on
my mother's side
another grandfather who was a great
entrepreneur
he made suits and built up a company
that then he became tailored to the
president
of the united states of america
president johnson but he also then took
a full-page ad opposing the vietnam war
full knowing he would lose his most
important client but i was raised with
the idea that you stand up for what you
believe in no matter what the
consequences
and you i have to go a little off script
here you mentioning your grandfather
and president johnson a lot of us here
want to be leaders in our community and
many of us that will come from the
private sector from from being business
leaders
it sounds like that was an early
iteration of taking a stance
on an issue as a business leader even
though it might hurt your business
i'm curious you know we've seen this
view of changing from shareholder
capitalism to stakeholder capitalism and
in different views of what it means to
be a business leader in the political
realm
um what's your view on on should
businesses take political viewpoints and
and how can they do that
i mean it's tough if you're the head of
a publicly traded company
versus starting something that's your
own i would say
as much as you can do because politics
is not something that just exists
with people like me or in city halls the
white house
congress and state legislatures it
actually exists everywhere
politics you know the word for city in
greek
has the same root as what we now use for
politics police
so people came to cities in order to
engage with each other and part of that
obligation of citizenship
was to engage in politics and it's such
a cynical moment when people are like oh
i hate everybody and all leaders stink
and politics is dirty
and corrupt and think people are bad you
got to look at yourself and say no
each one of us if whether you believe in
god or whether you're just a
raging humanist a democracy which we're
lucky enough to live in
should reflect its people and if you
believe in people
either in god's image or because of your
humanism
it should be a reflection of our very
best so just because
politics feels like something you don't
do i think in the business environment
you always are forced to what's your
supply chain what's the impact
of the workers who put together if
you're manufacturing the material that
you sell
why are you waiting so long to get
diversity into your c-suite in the city
of la
i looked and government's supposed to
move slowly and in the first six months
brought gender equality to over 200
board commissioners
who you know run the police department
the port the
airport you know that can be done quite
quickly if we could do that in six
months
why can't you do it in your company so i
think politics comes in in a very
personal way
first and foremost and if you have the
foundation for that it's a springboard
to then organize across
business and in the private sector
around climate around racial justice
around whatever
it is uh to have a voice because the
private sector can be extremely powerful
when you do
and you mentioned there are some of the
issues that are on your plate as mayor
and to back up in 2013 you're elected
mayor
um at a sort of a difficult moment for
los angeles
in 2010 there were a million more
residents in los angeles than in 1980
but 165 000 fewer jobs los angeles had
one of if not the highest poverty rate
in the country
when you step into that role with so
many different problems and 4 million
constituents each with a different view
of
what you should be prioritizing and
working on how do you as a leader
decide what to prioritize it's a great
question
um because you know it's it's funny when
people say only a few people run the
entire country
i've you know been to the white house
enough times that i used to reject that
it's actually true i mean a lot of
people actually
run the country but the main decisions
and the direction of a city of a country
of a company really do come down to a
few people who hopefully listen to a lot
and then synthesize that and are able to
produce
a new direction for me in los angeles it
was natural i'd already been here for 12
years as a city council member
this was my first executive job really
in my life though at this level and it
kind of felt like a
um an off-the-rack suit that fit like a
custom-made one i mean it was something
i had been waiting for
uh in many ways my whole life and love
just being an executive and
finding talent and inspiring people but
the way i organized it was three-fold
one what's the core of what you're
supposed to do and focus on that
in politics so many people think about
oh i want to do the big sexy legislation
when people expect government to serve
them certainly the municipal level
fix my potholes take care of my public
safety issue
make sure the bus comes on time i mean
we literally make sure the train's right
on time
so i had a back to basics message which
for somebody who
considers myself kind of progressive and
idealistic and loves the visionary
part i i always had to discipline myself
and i think it's the same with a company
what's the core of what you do
and get that right if you get that right
you can elevate to the next level
and for me then what were the big
challenges facing my city
whether it was jobs which since 1992 we
had gone down in jobs
um and building up a new peak in jobs
which we did um whether it's
traffic whether it was climate change
whether it's housing and homelessness
tackle the big
problems and you might not finish them
while you're there but lay down the
foundation for that
which takes you to the third level
govern and lead
as if you're looking at yourself 5 10
and 25 years from now
don't worry about the headlines of today
don't worry about the criticisms of
tomorrow
really think about what i do today
will it be judged five and ten years
from now as the right thing and if so
don't worry about the noise
mike bloomberg who overlapped with me
you know actually passed that lesson on
to me he said the things that i was
least popular for are the ones that now
people look back and are more
most glad that i did and that really
stuck with me
to take one of those issues as an
example you know housing and
homelessness
it's such a broad problem it is systemic
you know it is um it's still very much
an issue especially given this pandemic
and the economic crisis
how do you approach such a long-term
systemic issue and and
break it down and you know it's it's
still ongoing i'm curious
how you um have seen some progress but
what's still to be done there
yeah i think the biggest issues whether
it's climate change which you know you
can
toil away for five years people are
saying they're still heating up
homelessness you can do amazing things
and people say it's still there and
encampments are growing or
things like gender and racial equality
which you can continue pushing forward
and then see
you know that we still have racism and
sexism and homophobia and all these
things
to me um i'll answer that two ways one
is you first have to deal with what's
in front of you and i looked kind of
back in history i think it's really
important when the
pandemic was coming i did the same thing
educate yourself about those who have
come before because nothing is new
this might be a new iteration it might
be a new incarnation
but it's an old challenge and there's
old history to learn from
um and so you know here in los angeles
we had talked about policies for things
like inclusionary zoning to mandate
affordable housing when market rate
housing is built
tom bradley our greatest mayor tried
that 40 years ago and not gotten it
through
uh we passed that we looked at for a
long time people said we need a
dedicated source of funding for
homelessness
we've passed not just one measure to
build 10 thousand units of housing but
two a county-wide services sales tax to
allow
uh the services to go with that housing
etc we did all of those things that
people really had talked about for
decades and those are so important again
we might not see the results of them in
two or three years but you'll see them
in a decade
long of steady work but second i
approach it systemically
and systematically which is to look at
something like
homelessness i've you know at the local
level it's funny i run a city
and people say mayor that's your city
there's people on the streets fix it
then i explained to them let's boil down
homelessness it's trauma
meets high rent the city of los angeles
doesn't control our child welfare system
our veteran system
our jails and our prisons it doesn't
control what happens with sexual and
domestic violence
it doesn't control you know much of the
economy
we can uh do zoning but we don't uh do
the capital outlays for big
housing so most of the cause is in and
the cures out
of homelessness have nothing to do with
anything i have direct power i have
sanitation workers and police officers
but cleaning and arresting your way out
of homelessness
is not a solution so i've come to the
point where i'm really speaking bluntly
with people saying if you want
homelessness to
end it's not going to come from me or
the next mayor or the next mayor
it has to come from a national right to
housing and every country that i looked
at in the world that's eliminated
homelessness
has a right to housing and think about
this with hunger and with health care in
america
we decided at some point people
shouldn't go hungry if you qualify for
food stamps 100
of people qualify get them so they don't
starve if you qualify for
health care and you're poor you get
medicaid we call it medi-cal in
california same thing with poverty for
seniors and
social security but here in america the
biggest housing initiative we have
called section 8 which is a voucher you
can take out there
nationally one in four people that
qualify get it in los angeles it's one
out of eight
and so that means people wait decades
and seven out of eight many of them live
on our streets so i worked with both
bernie sanders and joe biden and became
national co-chair of joe's campaign
and when he when he asked me to do that
he said what do you want i said i don't
want anything personally
but i want you to put in a platform that
we would expand to an entitlement
section 8
housing and i do believe that we can
solve people's mental health we can
solve people's
um job training needs we can solve what
brings them to the street their
addictions and other things
in some cases if we get them in housing
first but there's no city that will ever
have enough money to do that without
national help
and something you alluded to there is
not only are you working with
your city council and people on the
ground in los angeles but
you're increasingly working with other
mayors with governors with
the federal government and you know you
led a coalition of mayors against
homelessness you've been
at the forefront of the climate movement
led by mayors after the u.s pulled out
of the paris agreement
how have you seen the role of mayor what
does mayor mean in 2020
and how has mayor's mayorship changed
since
um you know 2010 or 2000 just over the
last couple decades
you know bill clinton once said the two
best jobs in politics are president of
the united states and mayor of a big
city in america
um it's funny i shared that story once
in the oval office was then president
barack obama who was
asking if i wanted to be his urban czar
and kind of oversee all the urban
policies it was the week that the
obamacare website had gone down just
after went live
and he said you can scratch uh the first
one from that list so
um you know i think the power that you
have as a mayor
is amazing i mean i run the largest port
in the americas
the fourth busiest airport in the world
and second biggest in the country the
largest municipal utility
um and that's before you start with the
normal stuff the police fire you know
talk about police and reform and racial
justice like i get to do that in real
time
um let alone fixing people's problems
and things like that but the network
between mayors has never been more
important
and has never been stronger it really
has been part of my story
and i think the story of cities and the
globe right now for instance i chair the
the title that i'm
proudest to have besides mayor well
proudest is his husband and
father but the professional title is
chair of c40 cities
this was is a group of cities the
largest cities in the world there's 97
of us now so the number is a little off
but
97 cities that comprise a quarter of the
world's gdp so collectively more than
any nation
and we're combating climate change
together but during this covet 19
crisis we hit the bat signal and put
together the most moving zoom call i've
been a part of 55 mayors of the greatest
cities of the world were on
the call together in the middle of the
beginning of this pandemic
so we had the mayor of milan when
northern italy was the place that you
know people were in the hallways of
hospitals
the mayor of seoul when they were the
model for testing the mayor of new delhi
who had just shut down
delhi and two days later a billion
people got a stay-at-home order when his
national government
followed and so whether it's gender
equity migration climate change
whether it's global or domestically i
chair also climate mayors which is now
450
mayors when president trump said we're
getting out of the paris climate accords
we didn't cry in a corner we just picked
up the phone and
republican democratic independent mayors
from 48 states said if he's out we're in
so i always tell people don't see the
power you have before you try to
exercise it
when everybody was so upset those who
didn't like president trump
that of the trauma he was giving a lot
of people and the power he was trying to
exercise over us said even if it was
hillary clinton as president that power
would have been in our hands that
responsibility would have been in our
hands
and we haven't lost that with president
trump so that network is really changing
the world
moving it and cities i think we're going
to accelerate their importance for the
next half century
about a little over half the world now
lives in cities i think it's going to
70 percent over the next 20 or 30 years
and and you've called cities the
laboratory for democracy and
and innovation what is the future of
cities you know what's los angeles or a
big city going to look like in 2030 or
2040.
well it's really up to all of us to to
explore and to
mold both from the public private and
civic sectors uh but the vision i'm
uh have here you know i'm very excited
we have this date um
now less than 10 years from now when the
olympic games and the paralympic games
will come to los angeles my first act as
mayor was to write a letter to the
olympic committee saying we wanted to
pursue the games
we lost the us nomination to boston then
they dropped out it was a long
circuitous road of resilience but la
loves the olympics and as a kid i saw
them come to my city in 1984
it was the best experience of my life
and it's a it's a
point on the horizon where we can kind
of align a vision of what we want a city
to be
to me i think cities are going to be the
systems
because cities are a system of systems
are going to pretty radically shift
uh the two-dimensional disruption we've
seen in commerce and communications
think one-click ordering and timing is
now going to come into three dimensions
uh we're going to see transportation
modes change whether that's underground
and things like
hyperloop or the um you know boring
company or whether it's
airborne taxis that move through our
spaces we're working with
companies like google to literally map
out the three-dimensional space of
cities
so that we can understand and um make
sure people are safe in that space but
use that for everything from moving
commerce to people
i think they'll be more equitable and
more livable cities i think people
really want to have
the concentration of jobs of housing
and of recreational activities
all in the same neighborhood rather than
the old city especially in california
and los angeles embodies this
where you put one thing over there and
20 minutes by car
over there and 20 minutes by car over
there because now you can't get three
blocks in 20 minutes
um i also think that it'll be a place
still of radical innovation
a place of deep investment and why i
would not
ever walk away from cities or l.a
specifically is what i've tried to put
in place
is a four to five decade uh
long strategy of infrastructure so we're
going to be building 15 rapid transit
lines the largest
infrastructure initiative in u.s history
times two i passed a few years ago
called measure m everybody thinks of us
as the car place and what we wrote into
that is it could be
light rail it could be bus ways but we
also left that open for the technologies
that will emerge what we guaranteed was
the funding
in place we're going to recycle 100 of
our water we're going to have
zero carbon buildings zero carbon
electricity zero carbon transportation
so it'll be much more sustainable and
then finally and that is my hope
we'll see cities that really are a place
for much more of a middle
class and more more justice and equity
for folks because
right now cities are either left behind
cities
or hyper successful cities that are
barbell cities both on
equity and on opportunity and we have to
fix that we have to fix that i believe
through education mostly but we also
have to fix it by the way we structure
our economy and we're trying to put that
in the dna
of la and who gets to work here and just
again to my first point
who's missing what voices don't we hear
what forces what faces don't we see
and making sure that's a part of our
strategy and to your point there i think
we've seen
during the last couple weeks in these
elections you know not just a divide
between rural and urban but
los angeles is very much a microcosm for
for where america is going
i think in the 90s la became a majority
minority city meaning there are more
people of color than white folks and and
that's where the country will be in the
next
20 years or so how do you in this deeply
partisan moment that we're in that is
largely around very different views of
these demographic shifts that our
country is undergoing
how do you lead for people at both ends
you know you have constrict
constituents at either extreme with
different views um
during this partisanship how are you a
leader
you know there's two ways my advice to
people stop being so fearful of engaging
with each other
because in a vacuum of real engagement
it's you know
twitter flame wars and comments on
facebook pages
and hyper um ideologies
and i i don't mind by the way extreme
ideas
um on any part of the spectrum as long
as they don't take away my
my rights and they're not intolerant i
think you need new ideas
but when that becomes ideology and that
becomes something
um in which the form like i think the
left which i'm a part of
um sometimes unfortunately copies the
methodology
of what we've just seen from donald
trump because we think we have to fight
back in the same way and there's a cost
that we pay
my great second point is my greatest
fear right now is that there's a great
dehumanization
going on and part of that is because so
much of our interactions are virtual
this year but increasingly from
technology so much of it is virtual
so the cues that human beings are
created for to see in three dimensions
and to feel and to smell and to see
and to just kind of intuit are lost when
we
reduce people to not just two dimensions
visually
but two-dimensional personally so you
know for instance let's take
the hardest issue right now in america
in many ways policing and racial justice
so there's no question we have
dehumanized people of color in this
country
since the beginning of our history
people have that that lives
consciously and unconsciously in our
hearts our actions and our perceptions
so how do we recognize that within the
culture of our police departments and
public safety departments
but then when you read that 40 of people
support the police of generation z and
60 don't
and it's kind of cool to march on the
streets and say all cops are bastards
those are 20 something year old human
beings that do have guns
and a badge who've devoted their lives
to trying to protect lives
by and large they've been motivated by
something good and how do we bring
those conversations together instead of
pulling it apart because now we have
police officers who feel totally under
siege
and we need them to be the agents of
change and to build on the successes
of changing culture and even exceeding
some of their power to others to provide
those services
and how do we continue to not lose this
moment so that people of color don't see
this
as yet again one more year when people
took to the streets asked for some stuff
and there was just a little bit of
reform so to me that's just
one case but we dehumanize each other
right now i'm dehumanized all the time
sometimes it's in positive ways
oh my god mayor you're so amazing and
you've done such great things and you're
so perfect and
as i love to always barack obama said
ask my wife about me and the dishes
like we're human beings but we also get
dehumanized in a negative way people who
decide who you are
who attack you and leadership has never
been more challenging than right now
i think for ceos for mayors when i talk
to my fellow mayors i have a little
support group of 15 or 20 on a tech
stream and
you know we have people visiting our
houses and spray painting our
walls you know we've got people who are
camping out
and chaining themselves to our lobbies i
mean those things didn't happen
specifically to me but other mayors
and it is and and similarly in the
private sector you have a
real woke moment that's also meeting
lord of the flies and
leaders are trying to figure out how do
i navigate what is about racial justice
and what's just about good management
and personality
and so i guess i come back to the
leading right now takes a
re-humanization
and reminding people of those moments of
human connection
and even if we're a different
perspective even if i've done something
wrong and you want to
teach me what's better we have to do
that for by leading with love
not with the anger that we have
and mayor city i want to leave a few
minutes for audience q a but we're
asking one final question to all
speakers who come this year
and it's it's relevant to what you just
said the question is
during your toughest moments many of
which likely have come this year
as a leader what are the principles that
you turn to
um you know the principles that i turn
to as a leader
i mean i've got in practice i would say
always
innovate always accelerate
always collaborate and always
communicate i mean think about covid
i didn't wait for other cities to figure
it out or even bother whether it was my
jurisdiction to set up
testing centers be the first city to
close things down the first to mandate
masks the first to
erase the racial gap with
african-american deaths the first to
test people without symptoms
i just did it so it was innovate and
accelerate
but i couldn't have done that if i
hadn't spent seven years collaborating
you know people love to hate the big
city mayor in a region because
you might only be 40 of the population
but you get 99 of the headlines
i've met with 87 other mayors in my
region quarterly that i convened for
seven years so they trust me they know
me i listen to them
i elevate their voices so
collaboration's really important and
then for 74 times i've been before
my public communicating hard truths in
the middle of a crisis
i got sick of my own voice but i kept
doing it now it's thankfully once or
twice a week that will probably ramp up
given the rise right now
but it was daily for the first few
months and i think communication is
everything own your story tell your
story and
think like an author you're a narrator
once you get to be at the highest levels
of leadership you're a narrator
of a story you need to motivate people
around and then the personal things that
i
would say is be humble but be fearless
learn to listen it's more important than
learning how to speak
really learning how to listen and then
i'll come back to what i said in the
previous question lead with love
that really is you know my my motto
my team makes fun of me until they start
to adopt it and they see that it really
is
all those things as a good leader mean
nothing if you're not leading from a
moral place of love
mayor garcia we have a few questions
from students the first question
is from neha de la
thank you so much rex and mayor garcetti
thank you so much for being here today
my name
is neha i'm in nba2 coming from a
background in public policy
uh we have a new president-elect thanks
in part to your work
i'm not going to ask you whether you're
going to join the administration but
what i will ask you
is beyond what you already mentioned
around housing how can a biden
administration best support cities like
l.a
well you know i remember what it was
like when joe biden was in the white
house because it was just 2013 i was a
new mayor i was invited
um with about a dozen mayors from around
the country who had just been elected
from detroit and la and chattanooga and
new york and other places and i was
expecting to go there for a photo
op and we instead in the roosevelt room
had a two-hour private conversation
where they just listened to every city
and every city's incoming mayor talk
about america
i think first and foremost rather than
programs or people
it is that perspective that i'm just
looking forward to because once you
develop that relationship
and that listening um you don't know
when you'll need them you don't know
what you'll need them for you don't know
the great idea that you want to
take up to the national level for them
but establishing that relationship
and joe biden really is who you see he
has that heart he's a great talker and a
great listener
um and and knows what he's talking about
so i think
that's the way this first starts helping
cities specifically though i would set
up something like a local government
council
in the white house that would bring
together city county and some state
leaders to be a regular group to bounce
things off of and to ask for them to
distribute kind of
initiatives and then i would have an
urban agenda that starts really with
opportunity in our cities
um what what businesses closed down uh
what people did not get ppp
loans uh what workers disproportionately
lost their jobs in the latino community
for instance and a lot of people in
hospitality and frontline jobs
really have been decimated and and help
um
mayors and cities be the eyes and ears
of an american recovery
that's what i would wish thanks neha
next we have a question from brad austin
hey brad i'm eric garcetti uh
my name is brad austin and i'm a first
year mba student here at stanford uh and
also a proud angelino of
the past 10 years uh my question to you
is
how do you manage your longer term
vision for the city
while responding to shorter term demand
of residents and do you view these two
as mutually exclusive or not
no they're definitely not i mean certain
things you know an earthquake that
happens is an earthquake that happens
you have to respond to in real time but
think about how you rebuild from an
earthquake you better be doing that for
the long haul
strengthening buildings even more um you
know looking at ways to build greener
there's always an intersection of the
two you never have to cleave off between
but there is a good point there is that
the urgency
especially as a mayor i have 50 urgent
things a day
and it took me about a year as mayor to
recognize that if i was just a passive
leader waiting for my staff to brief me
about everything i could spend
all day long being briefed i have 38
enterprises that i oversee that
they're called city departments but you
know the port of la is
a business enterprise like i said the
busiest port in the americas
uh trying to take um something like
department of water and power
and make that 100 you know renewable
zero carbon
electricity grid that has short-term
consequences on reliability
if you don't do it the right way so you
have to be nimble enough i
kind of carved up my time in four
sections it was yes
some briefing time but only a quarter
rather than 90 percent
of a quarter of the time needed to be
kind of proactive management of my
people
checking in with them giving them
personal tips and policy tips a quarter
was my visioning time of like stepping
back
talking to others reading doing thinking
and then a quarter of the time is in
relational time
keep up those relationships that are
absolutely critical because if you
haven't talked to somebody in a few
years
and then you call say i need help you
haven't developed kind of
an intimacy that you're going to need in
moments of deep deep need so
there is the back and forth of the
urgent and the long term
but i think if you're good in leadership
you always tie those two things together
think about the urgency of this year
we built um in c40 a covet 19
recovery playbook with these mayors from
around the world a committee that i
constituted and the
mayor of milan was the chair of it but
we had an incredible mayor from each
continent write this script and it's all
about the long-term recovery
don't just build back what we had don't
return to normal
that isn't good enough we should be
rejecting fossil fuels as we
build our energy grids back we should
have no stimulus it's not a green
stimulus we should be investing in
public transit
above and beyond what was there before
if we want people to actually
a surge into the economy so what seems
urgent in
the now is really about the long term
visioning as well and i think good
leaders can combine those too
thank you thank you our last student
question is from jessica barzilla
hey jessica hi eric garcetti thank you
so much for
coming to speak to us as a fellow alum
of harvard westlake i wanted to ask you
what lessons you've carried with you
from high school and especially as
the classroom experience has gotten
totally warped and coveted
what do you think a high school
education should do and should be
i think high school education first and
foremost is about
your emotional development i know we
fixate so much on academic and
there's a lot of important academic
development but i've learned you know
be nice figure out people who are nice
to you
be around people that that uh celebrate
you
um rather than kind of denigrate you
um know who you know don't chase the
shiny things that seem shiny at the time
but really
you know my best friends my three best
friends are still my best friends from
seventh grade we did
we did plays together we were all you
know aspiring actors two are still
actors today
and and we hang out to this very day
and i think you know those life lessons
are so much more important than
the i mean i had extraordinary education
i remember many pieces
of that education i think the other
thing is to return to what i said before
is be fearless and try
everything um don't think you know
we all have imposter syndrome women
experience that especially people of
color especially
but you know you can pick you know the
third generation vanderbilt like air
whatever he's doing
you know everybody kind of wonders how
the hell am i here and that's okay
human beings are naturally uh
inquisitive and brave and we're
naturally kind of down on ourselves and
wondering like
whether we can do it or whether we're
frauds and we'll be failures
the other thing i learned was when you
try everything it's okay to fail
um you know in politics that's tough
lesson because if you're an entrepreneur
you can fail four times and if you're
fifth times a hit you are like a legend
in politics you do four things great but
you mess up once
it's done so it's the inverse kind of
leadership uh
reward but if we can bring more
entrepreneurialism and creativity to our
lives and i think that's something that
i learned
certainly in my education the world will
be okay
we are a stubborn people human beings we
are creative people human beings
um there's nothing including climate
change um
racial justice this pandemic that we
can't rise to
the day that i stopped believing in that
is the day i quit being a leader
here at stanford mayor garcia we like to
end with a quick lightning round
uh so one word answers or one sentence
answers are you ready
favorite thing about l.a
freedom most misunderstood thing about
l.a
walking most misunderstood thing about
being mayor
being all powerful tick tock or
instagram
heart tick tock daily practice instagram
you have to go away on an extended
vacation
and name one hollywood celebrity as
interim mayor
who do you turn to jimmy kimmel you do a
great job
i agree completely um
we know there's a lot of traffic despite
the walking comment in la what's mayor
garcetti listening to
in his car um
a little bit of everything often keith
jarrett my favorite i'm a pianist i have
a piano in my
office and he's he's the greatest and i
was very sad to learn he just recently
had a stroke and we'll never probably
play again
you have to be mayor of one city outside
of the us
which do you choose barcelona it's where
i got engaged and i love that city
awesome mayor garcia i know you have a
city to run thank you for
for joining us hopefully we can host you
here in person soon i would love that
and thank you so much rex and
and thank you to dean levin to all the
questions they were superb i really
enjoyed the conversation
and i sign off every night when i
address people this way but sending
everybody strength and love
look after your your mental your
spiritual well-being in a really tough
year
and we're gonna get through this
[Music]